hora de la información económica en
directo a América de France 24 por ello
me acompaña en el estudio mi compañero
Jorge Hurtado Jorge bienvenido vamos a
iniciar en nuestra región en América
Latina porque la aerolínea Ultra Air
anunció la suspensión de operaciones en
Colombia bueno la aerolínea colombiana
suspendió también la venta de tiquetes
luego de que no lograra concretar un
desembolso enorme con una entidad
bancaria local y esto pese a la
inyección de capital que recibió ultrair
la semana pasada para salir de una
crisis financiera que atraviesa la
compañía tomó la decisión de suspender
todas sus operaciones en el país entre
las razones sostiene que en las últimas
semanas los arrendadores de las
aeronaves empezaron a exigir pagos
inmediatos e incluso prepagos de los
insumos y servicios necesarios para la
operación algo que antes según ellos no
era común la superintendencia de
transporte había dicho que la aerolínea
presentaba una baja liquidez que le
hacía más difícil poder cumplir con sus
obligaciones al corto plazo las empresas
del sector al igual que
Ultra r y viva sufren el aumento de los
precios del combustible la devaluación
del peso colombiano frente al Dólar y
también la alta inflación ahora qué
pasará con Los viajeros afectados en
Colombia esto Dijo el ministro de
transporte Guillermo Reyes
Y lamentablemente nos comunicó el
presidente de la aerolínea suspensión de
operaciones con las tres aeronaves que
venían
utilizándose hasta la fecha venían con
seis cancelaron tres venían
reprogramando vuelos y ya se toma esta
decisión que nos genera pues obviamente
una gran alarma una afectación para
nuestros viajeros hemos activado
inmediatamente el plan de contingencia
El plan de Mando opuesto de mando
unificado con la aeronáutica la
superintendencias y hemos solicitado
inmediatamente al presidente directivas
de Ultra que nos mande el estado
pasajeros de vuelos confirmados que
tenían para estos días y la Semana Santa
Vamos a exigir la reprogramación o el
pago en efectivo de Los tiquetes porque
nos vamos hasta Rusia porque el
presidente Vladimir Putin admitió que
las sanciones occidentales pueden
provocar un impacto negativo en la
economía de este país Bueno Pensé que
Rusia logró esquivar de alguna forma
recesión económica el presidente Putin
llamó a su gabinete a no relajarse el
presidente apuesta a dinamizar la
demanda interna en ese país sin
burocracia dice la economía rusa se
contrajo un 3,2% en los primeros dos
meses de ese año en comparación con el
mismo periodo del 2022 Cuando comenzó la
actual invasión militar en Ucrania el
producto interno bruto ruso cayó en un
3,1% en febrero una décima porcentual
menos que en enero según los datos del
Ministerio de economía un informe
también sobre el estado de la economía
nacional fue presentado el día de hoy
escuchamos que decía el presidente Putin
las restricciones y legítimas impuestas
a la economía rusa a medio plazo pueden
en efecto tener un impacto negativo en
ella en este sentido debemos garantizar
Un aumento sostenible de la demanda
interna en esta situación es esta la que
se convierte en el factor principal del
crecimiento económico
tomando en cuenta que buena parte de los
ingresos de Rusia vienen de la venta de
gas y de petróleo que fueron sancionados
este sector se puede considerar que va
realmente mal realmente no la empresa
rusa gasprom continúa aumentando el
suministro de gas a China y espera
pronto llegar incluso al máximo nivel
previsto a través de un gasoducto
siberiano las importaciones chinas
procedentes de Rusia principalmente de
petróleo y gas aumentaron un 31,3%
respecto al año anterior en enero y
febrero hasta
18.600 millones de dólares esto ayuda a
Putin a compensar la pérdida de ingresos
después de que Estados Unidos Europa y
Japón bloquearan o limitaran de alguna
forma las importaciones gas por un
incluso está negociando con china un
posible proyecto de suministro adicional
a través de la vecina mongolia bueno
nosotros vamos a cambiar de tema para
darle seguimiento a las turbulencias
bancarias que enfrenta Estados Unidos
bueno según la agencia calificadora de
riesgo mur y los riesgos para el perfil
crediticio soberano de Estados Unidos
serían limitados por esta nueva crisis
de confianza la situación Se generó por
la quiebra de silicon y también de
signaturban que provocó una retirada
masiva de depósitos en bancos regionales
de Estados Unidos a pesar de que las
autoridades allí lanzaron medidas de
emergencia para reforzar la confianza la
agencia dijo que no esperaba costos
Fiscales directos significativos para El
soberano derivados está actual tensión
en el sector bancario pero si esta
situación se prolonga podría debilitar
la fortaleza económica y fiscal de
Estados Unidos que es la principal
Economía del mundo bueno y vamos a
cerrar con Los indicadores económicos de
esta jornada empezamos con Estados
Unidos ahí las acciones subieron Y los
tres principales índices terminaron con
un alza de al menos el 1% esto por las
perspectivas optimistas de Michael
Technology y otras empresas en Europa la
bolsa de Milán subió un 1,56% en su
tercera jornada consecutiva en positivo
esto Gracias a la buena racha de los
títulos bancarios y también los
tecnológicos y en América Latina la
Bolsa Mexicana de valores avanzó 1,27% y
junta Ya tres sesiones consecutivas
cerrando en positivo pues Jorge usted
muchas gracias por esta ampliación
económica nosotros continuamos aquí en
directo América con el debate
[Música]